pretty much there
thank you
good morning
everyone the sitting is
open just one announcement
from my side in relation to the decision
by the liebec committee to enter into
inter-institution and negotiations
pursuant to rule 71 paragraph one on the
European Union drugs agency file
announced at the opening of the session
on Monday 12th December I have received
no requests for a vote
political groups reaching at least the
medium threshold the committee May
therefore start the negotiations first
item on today's agenda is the council
and commission statements preparation of
the European council meeting of the 15th
of December 2022 tomorrow I give the
floor first for the council the minister
for European affairsbeck Nicholas you
have the floor
Madam president
Madden president of the European
commission honorable members tomorrow
leaders will meet in Brussels for the
December European Council following a
gathering today for the first
commemorative EU asean Summit
this is planned as a one-day European
Council starting on Thursday morning
with the usual exchange with European
Parliament president metzola
leaders are expected to discuss the
energy crisis and its consequences on
households and the economy in Russia's
escalating war of aggression against
Ukraine
they will also discuss security and
defense and are expected to have
strategic discussions on Southern
neighborhood and on transatlantic
relations
Russia is using winter as a weapon the
situation is serious in Ukraine where
Russia's ongoing campaign of systematic
missile strikes against civilian targets
including energy infrastructure and
utilities inflicts tribal suffering on
the Ukrainian people
leaders will condemn these strikes as a
crime for which there can be no impunity
and are expected to call on Russia to
immediately stop endangering the Safety
and Security of Civilian nuclear
facilities
leaders are also expected to call for
the provision of humanitarian and civil
protection assistance to Ukraine to be
intensified and for assistance in
restoring Ukraine's critical
infrastructure to help the country get
through the winter following up also on
yesterday's special conference in Paris
this includes stepping up our support
for Ukraine's most urgent infrastructure
needs as well as working with the
private sector to provide a sustainable
supply of priority equipment to Ukraine
we also remain committed to providing
political and Military Support to
Ukraine
the European peace facility as well as
the newly launched EU military
assistance Mission are key Tools in this
respect
Ukraine's Financial relief resilience
and long-term reconstruction will
further be addressed by leaders I would
like to thank the European Parliament
for your support and efforts to reach a
timely Solution on the MFA plus
assistance file
leaders are also expected to speak about
how to further increase Collective
pressure on Russia to end its war of
aggression and to withdraw its troops
from Ukraine
they will welcome the reinforcement of
the eu's restrictive measures including
through the oil price cap
leaders are also expected to speak about
how to further increase Collective
pressure on Russia to end its war of
aggression and to be
uh sorry I I have missed the paragraph
they will welcome the reinforcements of
the EU restrictive measures including
through the oil price Gap the aim is to
have the new sanction package formally
adopted ahead of the European Council
likely by a written procedure on energy
and economy the European Council will
review progress in the implementation of
its October conclusions
steep Energy prices touch all European
citizens and businesses and the issue
has been very high on the agenda of the
Czech presidency of the council leaders
will continue to work on a coordinated
approach to whether this crisis and
minimize the social and economic Fallout
they will discuss the impact of high
energy prices and Global developments on
our industrial Fabric and consider what
should be done to maintain our Global
competitiveness and develop our
technological leadership in the green
transition whilst preserving the global
Level Playing Field
leaders will also take stock of progress
on the latest energy measures proposed
by the commission and address the next
steps
we need to make sure we continue to deal
with the most immediate aspects of the
current energy crisis but also prepare
for next winter and develop together a
resilient system for the coming years
we must face out our dependency on
Russian energy exports accelerate the
green transition and ensure security of
Supply which will require stepping up
investment in infrastructure and
interconnections Innovation or renewable
energy and Energy Efficiency projects
turning to security and defense leaders
will follow up on their discussions in
March and may taking stock and providing
further guidance on the implementation
of the Strategic compass and the West
Side declaration
the EU is taking more responsibility for
its own security and its capacity to act
autonomously in defense matters this
includes strengthening the European
Defense and Industrial base of course
the transatlantic bond is reflected in
the EU strategic compass and the NATO
strategic concept remains key
the European Council is expected to call
on the council and the European
Parliament to swiftly adopt the European
Defense industry enforcement through
common procurement act the council
already adopted its position in early
December under the lead of the Czech
presidency
regarding the eu's commitment to work
with Partners on security and defense
the European Council should underline
the importance of instruments such as
the European peace facility and is
expected to welcome the agreement of the
council to increase epf's overall
Financial ceiling by two billions into
the 2023. the European Council will hold
a strategic discussion on relations with
the southern neighborhood leaders are
also expected to have a strategic
discussion on transatlantic relations
on the 6th of December the Western
Balkans Summit took place in Tirana EU
leaders and Western Balkans Partners
reconfirmed our strategic partnership
the Tirana declaration reaffirms the use
on equivocal support for the EU
perspective of the western Balkans
yesterday the council adopted
conclusions on the enlargement process
which the European Council is expected
to endorse as you can see a very rich
agenda thank you very much for your
attention
thank you very much Minister thank you
for all your work these past
six months and I'll give the flow to the
president of the European commissioner
thank you very much president dear
Roberta
Minister honorable members
it's exactly three years ago that I
stood here in front of the parliament
presenting the European green deal
Europe was the first continent to set
out a path towards climate neutrality
other countries had pledges we had a
plan
back then we were concerned for our
industry because of the unfair
competition of heavy polluters
today only three years later the
competition we face has radically
changed
a global Green Tech race has started
that is what we wanted that is what we
need because only when the most advanced
economies compete for NetZero future
will we reach our common goals to limit
global warming and to protect our
children's future
but
this new competition environment
also calls for rethink on our site
on how we support our industry's green
transition
and strengthen its Global Leadership
and that is what we will discuss
tomorrow at the European Council
and this is what I would like to focus
on today
let me first look at the challenging
situation our companies are facing today
Global gas supply remains tight
because of Russia's war of aggression
Russia has cut 80 percent of its
pipeline gas supply to the European
Union in the last eight months
but we have been able to compensate
we have Diversified we're saving energy
we are have boosted the role out of
Renewables we're skimming off the super
profits of companies energy producing
companies to take the money to support
vulnerable households and vulnerable
businesses we agreed to buy gas together
and we put forward a market correction
mechanism to limit this bikes in gas
prices
our storages are filled
so we are as a result safe for the
winter
I think we can be very proud of what
we've achieved despite the Russian
blackmail and I would like to take the
opportunity to thank the Czech president
presidency for what you have achieved in
the last six months this is great and
thank you very much for that
yet
indeed you deserve
and Applause
yet all this what we've done comes at a
cost
cheap supplies of Russian energy were
part of the business model
of many European Industries
that model has been Shattered by
Russia's attack on Ukraine
and the Inconvenient Truth is that model
will not come back
the International Energy agency has just
reminded us that in the absence of
Russian gas
Europe now faces structurally higher
fossil fuel import prices
so the only sustainable way for our smes
and our Industries
is the transition to renewable energy
renewable energy is not only affordable
but it's of course also homegrown and it
creates good jobs here in Europe
but this transition will not happen
overnight
and Global competition is getting
tougher
just look at the United States they have
recently approved a significant
investment plan
which also sets standards for Green Tech
sectors the so-called inflation
reduction Act
and let us be very clear first of all
supporting the clean transition is the
right thing to do
if you do it right
in a transparent manner
in a spirit of cooperation
and in a way that ensures a Level
Playing Field
so it should be a Race Against Time and
not a race against each other it should
be erased to the top and not a race to
the bottom
yet there is a risk that the inflation
reduction act can lead to unfair
competition
and three part aspects are particularly
worrisome
first of all the buy American logic that
underpins large parts of the IRA
second the tax breaks that could lead to
discrimination
and third the production subsidies that
could disadvantage European companies
we need to address these issues we need
to give our answer
our European IRA
and I see four main strengths of action
first of all we have to adjust our own
rules
to facilitate national public investment
in the transition
second we have to reassess the need of
further European public investment
in the transition
third point we have to work with the
United States to address some of the
most concerning aspects of this law and
of course the first topic is false topic
is we have to further accelerate our
transition to Green energy
so to my first point
we need to nurture
the further future generation of
industrial production
our own green tech Industrial basis this
one we have to strengthen
and we need to make sure
that investment Aid and tax credits
reach the concerned sectors more easily
and faster
and this is why we will in January put
forward a new framework to accelerate
the transition
it will make our state aid rules simpler
and faster for the years to come
and it will close the existing Gap to
Target the whole value chain of
strategic green sectors
including large-scale deployment and the
access to raw materials
this new framework will for example
allow member states
to take into account Global conditions
not only the European ones but the
global conditions
when providing providing aid for certain
Green Tech manufacturing products
that means for some green field
Investments member states can match
the subsidies of third countries and
this will give an incentive to companies
to continue to invest in the European
Union not to invest in the United States
but to be here to stay here and to
invest in the European Union
at the same time
we have to protect our single Market
from fragmentation and uncoordinated
responses so our Unity as a single
Market as 27. and we all know not all
member states have the same capacity
for large-scale investments in strategic
sectors
the famous Deep Pockets they are not
everywhere
and this leads me to my second point
we need a fair green transition in all
of Europe
so to Foster Green Tech across Europe
we need complementary European funding
and here repower EU is our tool
repower EU is the vehicle that supports
smes and industries while they
transition towards cheaper and cleaner
energy
and in this context I really want to
congratulate you and I'm very glad that
repower EU has been adopted this morning
so late this night and it enters into
Force beginning next year this is a big
step for what many many thanks to that
this is an enormous achievement here in
the parliament
thank you
it's good that we have repower EU now
I think at the same time
the need for acceleration for the
Renewables will also require
a boost of repower EU so that we can
properly address the new circumstances
that have been created through the IRA
this is for the short term
in the medium term however I think we
need a more structural solution
because we want European industry to
keep leading in the green transition
and this is why I introduced the idea of
a sovereignty fund
and I think the upcoming midterm review
of the mff around summer will be a good
opportunity to put forward our proposal
in more detail
the idea behind it
is very simple
Europe is a continent full of strength
our single Market is unique we have the
largest single Market worldwide
we have a highly skilled Workforce we
have world-class universities
we have a tightly woven network of
renowned research institutions
but we also need to Galvanize our strong
European industrial power in the global
fight against climate change
and that calls for common European
industrial policy with common European
funding
I am speaking of beefing up the
resources available
for Upstream research Innovation and
strategic projects at EU level just
think of hydrogen
semiconductors Quantum Computing AI
biotechnologies That's where we have to
do the Investments now
and for the first time
we will also bring European funding to
our successful important projects of
common European interests the
abbreviation
ipcis or IP size as some say
these are strategic Investments to
maintain our Global Leadership in the
Green Tech sector
my third point
we are working very closely with the
Biden Administration on the most
concerning aspects of the IRA
and we're discussing how to jointly
strengthen our clean energy and Industry
basis
and we need to make sure in these
discussions that our respective
incentive programs will be reinforcing
each other and that they do not come at
the expense of each other
think for example at the topic of the
topic of critical raw materials that are
needed for the Green Tech
today
the production and the processing and we
know all that of some of the most
urgently needed critical raw materials
are controlled by one single country and
that country is China
so we share the U.S concern about the
Strategic vulnerability that we do have
and one of the possible solutions
to overcome this Monopoly that China has
without any doubt would be for example
to create a raw materials club with the
United States and with other partners
with the aim to have reliability
transparency
Fair conditions value that stays in the
country where these raw materials are
being extracted and we stand ready to
work on all this heart to achieve this
kind of joining forces and strengthen
our industrial basis
finally
let us recall
all these actions serve for a bridge
it is the bridge for our clean tech
industry to transform from today's
costly fossil fuel energy
into the clean energy and affordable
energy the Renewables
we need there for this investment now
because these industries and our smes
need the support now till we have
achieved an energy environment again
that is Affordable that is clean and
that is secure
honorable members
let us never forget the bigger picture
a war is Raging at the borders of our
Union Russia is escalating its attacks
against civilian and civilian
infrastructure
and the brave people of Ukraine need all
our help
therefore it is not the time for trade
war with our closest partners and Ally
this is a time for our democracies to
join forces even more
to stand up for Ukraine I'm very glad
that we have agreed now for the next
round of our 18 billion euros Financial
package which will reach Ukraine early
January
Putin's war of aggression will fail
mainly for two reasons
the first one is of course the enormous
bravery and the enormous courage of the
Ukrainian people
but the second reason is
the international community's remarkable
Unity
and therefore let us stay strong let us
stand up for Ukraine let us be United
Slava Ukraine Merry Christmas and Long
Live Europe
thank you very much to the commission
president I give the floor now to the
chair of the Epp group Mumford Weber
Madam president of parliament but I'm
president of the commission Mr Beck dear
colleagues today's subject is the
preparation of the European Council but
before we go into this as an institution
I think we all are still under